c'est bien de belmont maïs ma femme m'a
quitté pour son patron au jour lors
d'une réception il avait gardé les micro
branché tout le monde l'a entendu se
faire démonter ya toujours pire
eh ben c'est le pire t'as plus rien ta
vie c'était ton couple et croisons une
expérience tu vas perdre tout des amis
aussi ne m'avait plu c'est pas parce que
tu es en train de sombrer tu dois
montrer avec toi sur taiwo pourrait se
consoler ensemble devant lui dans ma
grande baraque
dis moi que tu as pas envie devrait s'y
trouvent a du mérite de faire plaisir
après le traumatisme que tu viens de
subir
c'est sûr que la séparation était lui en
parler du mariage
je peux faire son mandat les biens j'ai
vu ta bien belle est tombée de cheval ça
arrive aux meilleurs mais il faut que
tron et en sel direct sinon tu feras du
poney tout avis
[Musique]
par leurs propres soldats si c'est non
je regardais ça lui soit salie c'est une
scop
avec toi ben t'es célibataire maintenant
et de personnes pourtant gueuler quand
tu abuses cqb go away j'ai vu passé mon
annif alors les copains m'ont fait une
surprise
pompey un peu vrai bon la bulle échos
j'ai un truc qu'il faut pas toucher la
ferrari 250 gto c'était bien mais bon ça
je peux le faire tous sont là
oh merde
oh
mais le chrono n'est pas deux
ah ouais
je suis petit quoi je vais acheter un
même à l'identique